if vaccines work the way they're
advertised in terms of granting immunity
why would a vaccinated person ever have
to worry about an unvaccinated person
why still wear masks post facts if the
receiver is vaccinated as well
um it's going to be about breakthrough
cases i think i think the only the only
thing that i can think of and i've i
have given this
some thought um is that
you know some number of people who get
vaccinated still can get sick with the
disease
that said um part of being vaccinated
is obviously about actually not getting
the disease and part of it is about
being able to return to
the life that you had before so um
i i don't know why we are being told
that vaccinated people need to be
worried about unvaccinated people
um you know so it's true at a
tiny level that you could get sick if
you're vaccinated
um but i think more
to the point this is once again not
science but social control this is about
this is about messaging a narrative and
reinforcing the you know like uh the
good people get vaccinated and the bad
people
um resist and you know and we can keep
going down
and going down the lines of you know
that all of us will fall into
at least one of these camps where
suddenly we're not the good person
anymore
and um and once that happens once you
recognize that you go like wow
you're not actually using logic with me
you're just you've just decided that i'm
not your tribe and therefore you can
hate me
yeah i think it's about punishing
independence
and uh it's also about making simple
rules that do not force you to
acknowledge a complexity
you know the idea that people who have
had kovid should obviously get the
vaccine too
that is anything but obvious and the
problem is
if you say well actually people who've
had covid
don't need the vaccine because they've
effectively had a vaccine
and these vaccines are more dangerous
than
they should be because we know nothing
about their long-term effect so
it's better to keep those people from
having the extra risk if you say that
you've what there's risk right so you've
done that so instead we're going to
expose lots of people to risk that they
don't need to face
i mean this is part of what i we tried
to get out i think a few weeks ago
when i was you know alarmed at the
um i don't remember if it was fizer and
moderna but one of the ceos said yeah
actually we think there's going to need
to be yearly boosters
and you know it is what it is you know
either either that's
true that this is more like a flu
vaccine than like a yellow fever vaccine
or not
but um if that's the case then having
had covid
is not you know it's not going to
provide lifetime immunity and
it may you know is it yearly is it twice
yearly is it once a year
every other year you know who why did we
just land on every year because that's
easy to put on your calendar
um in the case of flu because it's
seasonal um but is coveted seasonal
we kind of thought it might be but now i
don't know you know it's it's really
hard to tell that the data just are
we're not being shown the data in a
clear way and
so you know if the vaccines are
everything that we hope they are
um having had covid doesn't provide
lifetime immunity it seems
and um therefore in order to be
protected
you you know perhaps should should be
expected to get vaccinated at some point
that said um increasingly now
code vaccination is being required to do
stuff like go back to school
and uh and people are saying well it's
just like you know just like the mmr
vaccine
it's like well the mmr vaccine is once
as an adult and maybe you get
every 10 years your title is checked and
i don't actually even remember if that's
the case but it may just be once as an
adult
that's very different from if suddenly
we were told
you're required to get a flu vaccine and
i'm not equating fluency but i never
have but
it's very different from being told you
need to get a re-up on a vaccine every
single year
well there are two things in play one
is the decay of your existing immunity
and the other is the evolution of the
virus and its
need for a new vaccine that's up to date
yes and you've made this clarification
before and i
and i'm confused i didn't confuse them i
just didn't specifically
yeah um but the they're really very
different
and uh which one of these or both that
we're dealing with is important and the
fact is we know very little right
we're learning a lot about how this
thing is evolving now
how it's evolving in response to the
vaccine is a very important question
and then there's another question which
is how long does your immunity last to
the initial
uh variant um
you know maybe it does last a lifetime
but that doesn't buy you it doesn't get
you out of
boosters if the thing is evolving uh at
a rapid enough rate yeah
yeah that's right can family members who
got the copper 19 shot be sick with
cobit unknowingly with mild or no
symptoms and get other family members
sick
yes unfortunately it's rare presumably
but again breakthrough cases
i would say well so breakthrough cases
by breakthrough cases you mean variance
i mean no
i mean people again the data are crap
but what i have seen reported in the
media
is that some people who get vaccinated
still get sick with covid and can
therefore pass it on because they when
they do
when vaccinated people do get sick they
tend to be low symptomatic or
asymptomatic
and so they might i think therefore be
slightly
more likely um to pass it on because not
only are they non-symptomatic but
because they're vaccinated they think
they couldn't possibly have it
right so non-symptomatic uh
or low symptomatic they may be less
contagious but so i would point out
again here's there's a hidden dichotomy
too because
there are people who are fully
vaccinated who are nonetheless
sick and contagious at whatever level
they are
and then there's the gert vandenbosch
point
which is people on the way to being
immune are not fully immune and they may
be in danger of spreading a variant
or selecting for a variant that they
could then pass on which would be even
more dangerous because it would be it
would evade
existing immunities from either having
covet already
or from being vaccinated so the next
question actually
speaks to his argument as well is bush's
argument about vaccines
similar to the concern over antibiotic
resistant super bacteria
if other nations are going to over
vaccinate any way shouldn't we
it's a tragedy of the commons that's
really two questions in there but um
it does seem analogous to antibiotic
resistance yes
in every way but one and i want to think
through the one
very very carefully but antibiotic
resistance
there's actually a solution for us
at whatever point we get wise enough to
decide to take it
right which is yeah if you want to take
your antibiotics out of circulation for
a long enough period of time you can
restore
the utility of them and that's because
all of that antibiotic resistance has a
cost and if it's not paying back
because the antibiotic in question isn't
in the environment so it's not favoring
the variants that have the resistance
it will go away so you can reset that
clock i don't
know of an analogous mechanism that will
allow you to reset
covid um kovid appears to be like
running on a treadmill rather than
some research well it's yeah it's not
actually
really analogous in this way because
with antibiotic resistant super bacteria
incomplete application of the
antibiotics
is allowing the bacteria to become
resistant to them so you take the
antibiotics
out of circulation entirely for say 30
years or whatever the amount of time
would be
and then upon reintroduction those
bacteria that have since evolved many
many many
you know thousands hundreds of thousands
of generations um
are now naive to those antibiotics
whereas
um there's no it's just not the same
logic with vaccines and and covet it's
not about
you don't you don't want naivete well
let's put it this way because we're
talking about a virus
yeah the calculus is very different
because the thing that causes the
antibiotic resistance to disappear is
that the bacteria or
fungi uh are organisms
and that means that they have um
conservation laws that they are paying
the price for things but
viruses borrow all of their physiology
from the creature that they infect and
it's a very different calculus so i'm
not sure
that there's nothing analogous but i
don't even know i know how to
fix a uh uh antibiotic
that's no longer working i don't know
how to do the same trick
for um for vaccines i agree
exactly right so that's actually
interesting both of us at first were
like yeah it kind of is
like actually not it is to a point
and and but then in terms of like
mechanistically how to deal with the
problem right it's not
solution-wise it's not but cause-wise it
is the point is
incomplete application of either
a vaccine or an antibiotic
causes the thing that you're trying to
fight to
evolve a sophistication that it doesn't
currently have so
yes yes it's analogous to that point and
then what you do about it i think is not
analogous yeah i agree i think that's
right
[Music]